[Music]
we have price
there's Salman and then there's like
onions and I think mango smells like
sushi and it looks like a taco have you
ever seen anything more beautiful in a
taco combined with sushi - my favorite
foods and then this is like a crunchy
tempura seaweed
I think anything shaped like a taco is a
win oh I don't follow hmm
the kind of taste like something with
tempura on it I like it a lot so many
different textures flavors crunchy soft
then you could use more of a vegetable
element like in the cross-section it's
pretty much just raw fish and then rice
underneath so it's kind of soft on soft
wish there was like rock cucumber or
like an avocado layer or something like
that you want to try it if you look
there could be more flavor looks
slightly bland but you like bland food
so I like the crunch the rice is just
like filler fish tastes fresh I love
mangos I don't like mangos but I liked
it which is interesting
Yong Ming goes wrong with you
it really just feels like real fish
inside something crunchy Wow
you would not think this would work out
it's like super crispy and like I love
seaweed and there's rice and I love rice
the temper of seaweed as a shell stroke
of genius this is a symphony of flavor
follow up question where do I get this
who makes this I don't even know if you
could consider it the sushi but it's
like a sushi inspired taco it has a
really good finger though I really like
it it's good I would eat this again for
sure
can we keep this turn our time we'll
need a gun you won't burn hmm yes camera
eat the top
[Music]